perhaps we could start by just telling
us about your country it's three dots
there on the globe but those dots are
pretty huge I think each one is about
the size of California tell us about
your bus well let me first begin by
saying our deeply grateful I am for this
opportunity to share my story with
people who do care I think I've been
sharing my story with a lot of people
who don't care too much
but syllabus is comprised of three
groups of islands the Gilberts group on
the the west we have the the phoenix
islands in the in the middle and the the
line islands on the under in the east
and quite frankly kilobase is perhaps
the only country that is actually in the
four corners of the world because we're
in the Northern Hemisphere and the
southern hemisphere and also in the east
and the west of the International
Dateline these islands are almost
entirely made of ethyl coral atolls and
on average about two meters above sea
level so this is what we have on usually
then usually not more than two
kilometers in width and so I've in many
occasions have been asked by people you
know you're suffering why don't you move
back and I they don't understand they
have no concept of what it is that's
involved with the rising sea they they
say what well you can move back and so
this is what I tell them we move back
and we will fall off on the other side
of the ocean okay and but this is like
these are the kind of issues that people
don't understand so certainly this is
just a picture of fragility there when
was it that you yourself realized that
there might be impending peril for your
country or the story of climate change
has been one that's been going on for
quite a number of decades and when I
came into office I I in 2003 I I began
talking about climate change at the
United Nations General Assembly but not
with so much passion because then there
was still this controversy among
the scientists whether it was human
induced it was a real or it wasn't and
but I think God that debate was fairly
much concluded in 2007 with the the the
the fourth assessment report of the IPCC
which concluded made a caracal
categorical statement that it is real
it's human induced and it's predicting
some very very serious scenarios for
countries like mine then so that's when
I got very serious in the past I talked
about it that's as we were worried but
when the scenarios the predictions came
in 2007 it became a real issue for us
now that those predictions I think that
by 2100 sea levels of forecasts arrive
perhaps 3 feet there are scenarios where
it's higher than that for sure
but what would you say to a skeptic who
said it was 3 feet on average 6 feet
above sea level what's the problem well
I think it's got to be understood that
imagine a rise in sea level would mean a
loss of a lot of land because a lot of
much of the land is so I'm quite apart
from that we're getting the the swells
at the moment so it's not about getting
2 feet I think what many people do not
understand this they think climate
change is something that is happening in
the future
well we're at the very end bottom end of
the spectrum it's already with us we
have we have communities who already
have been dislocated they have had to
move and every parliament session I'm
getting complaints from different
communities asking for assistance to
build Seawolves
to see what we can do about the
freshwater legs because it's being
destroyed and so in my trips to the
different islands I'm I'm seeing
evidence of communities which are now
having to cope with the loss of food
crops the the contamination of the water
at the water lines and I see these
communities perhaps living having to
relocate within 5 to 10 years and then
and I think that the country suffered
its first cyclone and this is connected
yes what what what happened here
well we we're on the equator and I'm
sure many of you understand it when
you're on you're on the equator it's
supposed to be in the doldrums we're not
supposed to get the Cyclones we create
them and then we send them either north
or south but they're not supposed to
come back but for the first time at the
beginning of this year the cyclone pam
which destroyed Vanuatu
and in the process at the very edges of
it actually touched our 2,000 most
islands and all of Tuvalu tavola was
under water when hurricane Pam struck
but for our two southernmost islands we
had waves come over half the island and
so this has never happened before it's a
new experience and there was another
I've just come back from my own
constituency and I've seen these
Bridgeford trees which been there for
decades that they've been totally
destroyed and so this is what's
happening but I think when we talk about
the rise in sea level we think it's
something that happens gradually it
comes with the winds it comes with the
swells and so they can be magnified but
what we are beginning to witness is the
the change in the weather pattern which
is perhaps the more urgent challenge the
challenge that will face sooner than
perhaps the rise in sea level so the
country is already seeing effects now as
you look forward what are your options
as a country as a nation well I've been
telling this story every year I think I
visit the number of I've been traveling
the world to try and get people to
understand we we have a plan we think we
have a plan and I've been on one
occasion I think I spoke in Geneva and
there was a gentleman who was
interviewing me on something like this
and I said there we are looking at
floating islands and he thought it was
funny but somebody said no this is not
funny
these people are looking for solutions
and so I have been looking at floating
islands the Japanese
they are interested in building floating
islands but we have as a country we have
made a commitment that no matter what
happens we will try as much as possible
to stay and continue to exist as a
nation what that will take it's it's
going to be something quite significant
very very substantial either we live on
floating islands or we we have to build
up the islands to continue to stay out
of the water as the sea level rises and
as the storms get more severe and so but
even that it's it's going to be very
very difficult to get the kind of
resourcing that we would need and then
the only recourse is some form of forced
migration well we we are also looking at
that because in the event that nothing
comes forward from the international
community
we are preparing we will we don't want
to be caught like what's happening in
Europe okay we don't want to mess my
grades at some point in time we want to
be able to give the people the choice
today those who choose and what to do
that to do migrate with that one
something to happen that that they are
forced to migrate without having been
prepared to do so of course our culture
is very different our society is very
different
and once we migrate into a different
environment the different culture
there's a whole lot of adjustments that
I require well this forced migration in
your country's past and I think just
this week I think just yesterday or the
day before yesterday you you visited
these people tell what happened here
what's the story here yes and I I'm
sorry I think somebody was asking why we
were sneaking off to visit at that place
we had a I had a very good reason
because we have a community of cuba's
people living in that that part of the
Solomon Islands but these were people
who were relocated from the phoenix
islands in fact in the 1960s there was a
there were serious droughts and the
people could not continue to live on the
island and so they were removed to to
live here in the solomon islands and so
yesterday it was very interesting to
meet with these people they didn't know
who I was ahead of me some of them later
recognized me but they were I think they
were very happy later they wanted to
they really wanted to have the
opportunity
to welcome me formally but I think what
I saw yesterday was very interesting
because here I see our people as I spoke
in our language and of course they spoke
back they replied but the direction the
beginning not to be able to speak
kilobits properly I saw them there was
this lady with red teeth see when she
was chewing betel nuts and it's not
something we doing killer but we don't
chew bitterness and I saw I met also a
family who have married the local people
here and so this is what is happening
there is as you go into another
community there are bound to be changes
there is a bound there's bound to be a
certain loss of identity and I think
this is what we will be looking for in
the future if and when we do migrate
what's to mean just an extraordinary
emotional day because you're because of
these questions about identity and that
the joy of seeing you and perhaps an
emphasized sense of what they had lost
and it's very inspiring to hear you say
you're gonna fight to the end to try and
preserve the nation and in you know in a
location this is our wish nobody wants
able to leave their home and so it's
been a very difficult decision for me as
a leader you don't make plans to to
leave your Island to your home bed and
so I've been asked a number of occasions
so how how do you feel and I know it
doesn't feel good at all it's um it's an
emotional thing and I I've tried to live
with it and I know that on occasions I'm
I'm accused of not trying to solve the
problem because I I can't solve the
problem it's it's a it's something
that's got to be done collectively
climate change is a global phenomenon
and as I've often argued unfortunately
the countries when we come to the United
Nations where I was in the in a meeting
with of Pacific island for a mile
countries where Australia New Zealand
they're also members and we had an
argument and I think there was a bit of
a story in the news because they were
arguing that to cut emissions it would
be something that they're unable to do
because it would affect
the industries and so here I was saying
okay I hear you I understand what you're
saying but try also to understand what
I'm saying because if you do not cut
your emissions then our survival is on
the line and so it's a matter for you to
weigh this these moral issues and it's
about industry are supposed to be
survival of people you know I asked you
yesterday what made you angry and you
said I don't get angry but then you
paused I think this this made you angry
alright um I I'd refer you to my earlier
statements at the United Nations I was
very angry very frustrated there was and
then depressed there was a sense of
futility that we're fighting a fight
that we had no hope of winning and I had
to change my my approach I had to become
more reasonable because I thought people
listened to somebody who was rational
but I remained radically rational
whatever that is now a core part of your
nations identity is fish eh I mean I
think you said pretty much everyone is
involved in fishing in some way well we
eat fish every day every day and I think
there is no doubt that our rate of
consumption of fish is perhaps the
highest in the world we have we don't
have a lot of livestock so it's fish
that we depend on
so you're dependent on fish both at
local level and for the revenues that
the country receives from global fishing
business for tuna and yet despite that a
few years ago you took a very radical
step can you tell us about that
I think this something happened right
here in the Phoenix Island well let me
give some of the background of what it
is how what fish means for us we have
one of the largest tuna fishery
remaining in the world in the in the
Pacific I think we host something like
60% of the remaining tuna fishery and it
remains relatively healthy for some
species but not all and kilobases
certainly one of the three major
resource owners of tuna resource orders
and we could at the moment we'll be
getting something like 80 80 to 90
percent of our revenue from
access officials license fees of you of
your national national national revenue
which drives everything that we do in
governments hospitals schools and what
have you but we decided to close this
and it was a very difficult decision I
can assure you I it politically locally
it was not easy but I I was convinced
that we had to do this in order to
ensure that the fishery remains
sustainable they'd been some indications
that some of the species in particular
the the big I was under serious threat
the elephant was also heavily fished
skipjack remains healthy and so we had
to do something like that and so that
was the reason I did that another reason
which before why I did that was because
I'd been asking the international
community that in order to deal with
climate change in order to fight climate
change there's got to be sacrifice
there's got to be commitment and so in
asking the international community to
make a sector support and sacrifice
I thought we ourselves need to make that
sacrifice and so we made the sacrifice
and that the foregoing commercial
fishing in the Phoenix islands
particular area would mean a loss of
revenue we are still trying to assess
what that loss would be because we we
actually we actually closed it off at
the beginning of this year and so we
will see by the end of this year what it
means in terms of the the lost revenue
so there's so many things playing into
this on the one hand it may prompt
healthier fisheries and and and that's
more I mean how much are you able to
move the price up that you charge for
the remaining area the there's been a
it's the negotiations have been very
difficult but we have managed to raise
the cost of a vessel day for any vessel
to come in to fish for a day we have
raised the fee from it was 6,000 and
8,000 now to 10,000 12,000 a parrot
vessel day
and so there's been that significant
increase but at the same time what
what's important to note to note is the
whereas in the past this this fishing
boats might be fishing in a day and
maybe catch 10 tons now they're catching
maybe a hundred tons because they become
so efficient and so we've got to respond
likewise we've got to be very very
careful because the the technology has
so improved there was a time when the
the the the the pass alien fleet moved
from the Atlantic to the Pacific they
couldn't they started experimenting to
if they could per se but now they've got
ways of doing it then they become so
efficient can you give us just a sense
of what it's like in those negotiations
because you're up against companies that
have hundreds of millions of dollars at
stake essentially how do you hold the
line how is there any advice you can
give to other leaders who are dealing
with the same companies about how to get
the most for your country get your most
for the fish now how do you how do you
what advice would you get well I I think
we focus too much too often on the
unlicensed thing in order to get the
rate of return because what we are
getting from license fees is about 10
percent of the landed value of the catch
on the side of the wolf not in the the
retail shops and I still we only get
about 10 percent what I what we have
been trying to do over the years is
actually to increase our participation
in the industry in the harvesting in the
processing and eventually hopefully the
marketing they're not they're not easy
to penetrate but we are working towards
that and yes the answer would be to
enhance - in order to increase our rate
of return we have to become more
involved and so we've started doing that
and we have to restructure the industry
we've got to tell these people that the
world has changed now we want to produce
the fish ourselves
I mean well for your local fishermen
there they still able to fish but what
what is
business like for them alike is it
getting harder as the waters depleted or
it's that being run on a sustainable
basis the for the additional fishery
with weather
we do not participate in the commercial
fishing activity except only if we just
apply to domestic market the the tuna
fishery is really entirely for the
foreign market mostly here in the US
Europe Japan and so the yeah well I'm a
fisherman very much so and I used to be
able to catch yellowfin
now it's very very rare to be able to
catch you'll often because they're being
lifted out of the water by the hundreds
of tons by the these procedures so
here's a couple of beautiful girls from
your country I mean as you think about
their future
what what message do you have for them
and what message would you have for the
world well I've been telling the world
that we really have to do something
about what is happening to the climate
because for us it's about the future of
these children I have 12 grandchildren
at least I think I have 12 my wife knows
and I think I have hmm
but it's about their future and every
day I see my grandchildren about the
same age as these young girls and I do
wonder and I get angry sometimes as I do
I wonder what is to become of them and
so it's about them that we should be
telling everybody that is not about
their own national interest because
climate change
regrettably unfortunately is viewed by
many countries as a national problem
it's not and this is the argument we got
until recently with our partners the
Australia New Zealand because they said
oh we can't cut any more with this is
what he said one of the leaders Chilean
leader said that we we've done our part
you know we've we are cutting back I
said what what about the rest why don't
you keep it if you if you could keep the
rest of your emissions within your body
within your borders would have no
question you can go ahead as much as you
do but unfortunately you're sending it
our way and it's affecting the future of
our children
so surely I think that is the heart of
the problem of climate change today we
will be meeting in Paris at the end of
this year but until we can think of this
as a global phenomenon because we
created individually as nations but it
affects everybody else and yet we refuse
to do anything about it and we deal with
it as a national problem which it is not
it is a global issue and it's gotta be
dealt with collectively people are
incredibly bad at responding to graphs
and numbers and you know we shut our
minds to it somehow
two people were slightly better at
responding to that sometimes and it it
seems like it's very possible that your
nation despite well actually because of
the intense problems you face you may
yet be the warning light to the world
that is shines most visibly most
powerfully I just want to thank you I'm
sure on behalf of all of us actually if
your extraordinary leadership and for
being here mr. president thank you sir